hey guys today it is the second of every
my name is just and you are watching
game switch first up Warner Brothers has
officially announced lego star wars the
force awakens the game will be out on
jun 28 across all of the platforms
including the nintendo ones and last
generation it will be set between Return
of the Jedi and the force awaken and
will provide extra insight into the
characters and plot of the force awakens
playable characters include all your
favorites from the film including rey
finn poe dameron han Solo Chewbacca and
bb-8 to name a few the game will also
incorporate jakku and the Starkiller
base among other locations Warner
Brothers has also suggested the game
will have new gameplay mechanics
including multi builds that let players
pick from multiple building options as
well as blaster battles and dog fights
in space a new world war two shooter
called battalion 1944 is in development
at bulkhead interaction the developer
have said the game aims to capture the
core of classic multiplayer shooters it
runs on Unreal Engine 4 and includes
real-world locations like Harrington and
bastogne while some of the weapons
include the car 98 m1 garand and
Thompson battalion 1944 is designed to
emphasize players skill and it will
feature a global competition system
called battle rank the game is currently
on Kickstarter and the devs are asking
for 100,000 pounds to get it off the
ground the last major FPS set in world
war two was Call of Duty's world at what
that is if you don't count the
Wolfenstein game theme nintendo
financials are out which is great
because it's been a good while since
we've all had a nice opportunity to
declare ourselves pro or anti nintendo
the company detailed their financial
results for the nine-month period ending
december 2015 and reported a decrease in
sales compared to the previous year but
an increase in operating profit that
marks the fifth year in a row when
nintendo sell
have declined but this is in part due to
the strong yen damaging exchange rates
since Nintendo makes three quarters of
its sales overseas in the last nine
months nintendo sold at 3.6 million we
use bringing their lifetime total to 12
million unit adds Nintendo of said the
new Nintendo 3ds and XL made up the bulk
of the three DF hardware sales stands
out game performers for the period were
animal crossing happy home designer on
3ds and splatoon and Super Mario maker
on Wii U Nintendo also took the time to
update the Wii U and 3ds software sales
charts which detailed the best-selling
birth party games I want wide on where
you mario kart 8 has sped ahead with 7.2
4 million copies that includes those
sold in bundles and digitally also high
on the list when you super mario
brothers you nintendoland Super Mario 3d
World and super smash brothers as for
the trustee 3ds pokemon X&Y led the pack
with 14.4 six million copies sold it was
followed up by Mario Kart 7 and Pokemon
Omega Ruby and alpha sapphire you can
check out the complete list in our story
on gamespot let me know down in my
comment section if you'd be keen on
playing a new world war 2 shooter you
can add the games well we've got stories
on EA's next on the house game and the
new rainbow six siege map that is
everything I have for you today as
always let me know your thoughts and
feelings on today's stories and I will
catch you again tomorrow
Oh